netflix is the witcher is pretty wild
straight out of the gate but season two
takes things to the next level and far
beyond new characters are invariably
interesting and returning characters
from kahir to geralt to rivia himself
receive significant personality boosts
and all sorts of new things to do when
it comes to the plot however it's all
about siri princess cirilla is at the
center of virtually every plot threat of
the season regardless of who's weaving
them as a result the vast majority of
the various characters plans in the show
evil or otherwise somehow revolve around
her and her largely untapped but
incredibly strong magical powers by the
ending of the witcher season 2 it's
clear that the season's more or less
been all about her which of course is
only fair play considering the run for
your life ringer 4 siri was put through
in season one when you first meet siri
in season one she's fearful and out of
necessity has to use the vast majority
of her energy to simply survive season
two siri on the other hand is on a much
stronger footing she's finally found
geralt and can now exist beyond simple
survival mode she's strong driven and
extremely determined to do whatever it
takes to get back to khahir even if you
don't take her magical powers into
account she's proving to be a commanding
presence and a tenacious warrior who
trains hard enough to actually impress
the witchers of karemorin but there's
one siri related scene in the witcher
season 2 that some fans think went too
far interestingly enough siri's all
permeating presence within the plot's
various threads doesn't seem to have
noticeably soured viewers to her in fact
freya allen's stellar work in the role
makes a character extremely easy to like
regardless of how much plot poor siri
has to carry on her back however some
fans hairs have been bristling because
of one particular incident in which siri
herself is largely a passive party
jennifer's decision to betray her and
use her as volath mirror's pawn in order
for yen to regain her own magical powers
in return i had no choice
like chaos
i thought i had to
[Music]
so sorry sir
one twitter user posted my main gripe is
that you've written characters
completely opposite of what they're
supposed to be i mean jennifer would
never betray siri another pointed out
book jennifer would never knowingly
betray siri things eventually turn out
as fine as they can within the context
of the witcher but siri and yennefer
might still have a long way to go before
they establish complete trust even
though circumstances obviously conspire
against them during the witcher season
2. still fans certainly seem to think
that this early breach of trust went too
far though some fans call out the
unfortunate bump on the road that's
jennifer's betrayal of siri the princess
herself seems to be largely beloved by
the season 2 fandom one fan wrote on
reddit love geralt siri and yen's
dynamic different from the books but
that is absolutely fine another agreed
posting actress who played siri did a
really good job this kind of warm
welcome to the new improved version of
the character is a testament to the
show's writing and direction after all
the princess goes through intense
physical training that regularly leaves
her bloody it's chased by multiple
terrifying monsters that are drawn to
her power and turns out to be arguably
the most important person on the entire
continent through all of this and more
the fans are on board despite the fact
that all of this focus leaves her with
ample potential to become the kind of
perfect heroine who could easily become
a less than-liked figure in the eyes of
the fandom the show clearly succeeds in
keeping siri likeable by communicating
that she's very much not your average
perfect fantasy princess with all this
potential and fan goodwill at her
disposal it will be fascinating to see
where her character is headed once the
witcher season 3 rolls in check out one
of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about the
witcher are coming soon subscribe to our
youtube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
you